I know it all sounds kind of heady but
this stuff is real there will be people
listening to this who says Ah does it
all need to be so difficult can't you
just be yourself and the answer is no
you shouldn't be someone you're not but
people Define being themselves as
holding on to all of the things that
make them make bad decisions that's not
being yourself that's that's not healing
Matthew has many many clips on YouTube
and social media that have gone
absolutely viral and he's one of the
world's most famous dating coaches in
particular dating coaches for women he's
written a book called get the guy which
became a New York Times bestseller my
friend said to me my dad goes to this
guy Tony Robbins every year he's doing
the Excel Center do you want to come I
couldn't believe that someone could
command the room like that and so that
was this Fusion of what I loved to learn
about with a delivery that I was
astounded by at that point I just
thought this is this is something I need
to be close to somehow Annie makes
videos on his YouTube channel with over
2 million subscribers and also his
podcast giving people advice on their
love lives and dating and relationships
the health of your relationship isn't
two-dimensional it's not just how many
things have I done for my partner today
we lose our value in dating
when we stop paying attention the
consequences of ignoring what I'm saying
are a life of suffering
just a very quick thing before we get
started if you have not yet subscribed
to the podcast either on YouTube or in
your favorite podcast app of choice then
please do it really helps us out a lot I
would love if we can just start with you
so you've been doing this
I guess career in inverted commas as
like a sort of dating relationship coach
expert you do videos you've got courses
you've got Retreats
how did how did how did all this start
and like what's I guess been the
trajectory of your career in this in
this over time because I'd love to dig
into the the details I what where did I
start I well I I was 11 years old I
think around about 10 or 11 when I was
rummaging through my dad's bookshelf
and he always wherever we lived and we
went through very different Financial
circumstances as a kid but whether we
lived somewhere lovely or not so lovely
there was always a bookshelf
my dad was very interested in
self-development so he had How to Win
Friends and Influence People on his
bookshelf and I One Day picked it up and
was hooked very quickly
I think I was a very shy kid
so the idea that you could learn
how to be in the world in a way that
would make more of an impact or make
social situations less
scary uh that was very very compelling
to me and when I read how to win friends
influence people and Influence People I
thought I had discovered some sort of
secret scroll that no one else knew
about I didn't realize it was a big book
do you know what I mean there was
nothing that said you know best seller
on the title or anything I just I
thought wow I found something here that
can really really make a difference
and I used to go into school and sort of
practice what I'd learned on teachers
and you know like I was almost more
comfortable actually doing
it with adults than I was people my own
age still couldn't talk to a girl at
school still terrified of that but I I
started to use it with adults and I had
a DJing
a career when I was a teenager
um that lasted for nearly a decade and
that was it was very useful in that you
know I knew I remember going to to do
sort of gigs for people my age but very
quickly realizing that it was the
parents that it was great to make
relationships with
um you know and and I would go after the
gig and hang out with the parents and
talk to them and so then I I ended up
going I got dragged by a friend's father
I say I got dragged he got dragged my
friend who who was my age
said to me my dad goes to this guy Tony
Robbins every year um he's playing he's
doing the Excel Center
I have to go do you want to come I have
a I have a ticket to bring a friend and
I he what he didn't know is that I'd
already read Tony Robbins book by that I
think I was about 14 at the time I'd
already read his book I'd already read
How to Win Friends and Influence People
I'd already been on my own little
self-development journey in private
and so the opportunity to go was
actually wildly exciting more exciting
than I let on yeah to him
and I went and it became the marriage of
all of this content that was really
exciting to me and suddenly a an ability
in delivery
that I had never seen before I hadn't
seen it in any of my teachers at school
I hadn't seen it anywhere else in life I
I just thought I couldn't believe that
someone could command a room like that
and
and so that then became like that was
this Fusion of what I loved to learn
about with a delivery that I was
astounded by and that sort of set me on
a path I won't say at that point I knew
what I wanted to do at that point I just
thought
this is this is something I need to be
close to somehow which has always been a
theme of my life I always think if you
like something you just don't worry
about what that means exactly just
find a way to get close to it somehow
and and that's where it started
um so everyone I've ever met who's been
been to a Tony Robbins event has just
like says that oh my God like seeing it
in real life is just a completely
different experience to watching it on
TV or on DVD tape or whatever it was
back in the day what was that experience
like for you and when you were 14.
it
it was genuinely electrifying I remember
just I have such good memories of that
because I felt like we were as actually
two friends he brought me and this other
guy and the three of us just sat there
we didn't sit with his dad with the
three of us just got to sit there and we
had the greatest time and I remember
just sort of that feeling of oh people
Just Dance here but there's no no one's
judging anyone else we're just we can
just have a dance and be silly you know
oh there's people crying here but no
one's sort of judging the fact that
you're crying or going through something
it was a very it was a very very
interesting environment and it was
and it was just you know Tony is
unbelievable at what he does and to to
be in the crowd as a recip you know
what's you know what's cool I think the
more you get involved in coaching
yourself or speaking or whatever
the harder it becomes to be a just a
truly vulnerable and active participant
in somebody else's shirt right yeah and
that's a shame and it shouldn't be that
way and and I fight against that and I I
try to just go and live as a like really
experience something
as as Matthew not as someone who in his
own life then works with people because
I think when she once you develop that
skin it's sort of over for you the the
learning the growth the vulnerability is
over for you and that's the beginning of
just
stagnation so but back then I didn't
have anything to prove to anyone I
didn't have to seem like I had it all
together in any way shape or form and
and so just I just got to
to be a participant and now that was
lovely oh amazing yeah I really want to
go to attorney Robbins event at some
point um his team invited us to
something that was virtual and we
thought oh you know the real life thing
could be interesting um you should you
should go because it's it's there's
something look what you know obviously
anyone could think what they like about
the content how useful it is to them
everyone has to make their own mind up
but I there is something to be learned
for everyone in
being in a room like that and and so
even just to learn about
impact or persuasion or making a case or
how to how to public speak even you know
how to how to how to have that kind of
impact on a room full of people I don't
everyone can learn the idea that anyone
could go into a room like that and just
go there's nothing for me here I don't
understand that mindset because you kind
of I remember
going back years later
when I was doing a lot of public
speaking and I remember going and saying
to myself okay
I am go this time I'm gonna go and I'm
just gonna go from the perspective of
learning everything I can from this
human being in terms of their ability to
connect with an audience
and and I really I went with that lens
and it was amazing I you know I remember
there were moments where I tried to hang
on what was I at the time maybe I was 20
20 21 19 maybe I but I remember trying
to get as close to the stage as possible
because I just wanted to see
you know what does he have on the stage
because I knew at that time I was
already public speaking and and I was
like what do I need on the stage how
many notes am I supposed to have what is
you know what does Mastery look like in
terms of how many times you look back at
your notes or whatever and I just
remember getting as close to the stage
as possible to try and see does he have
notes does he have a monitor what does
he use and that part fascinated me as
much as any other but that's probably me
geeking out from a public speaking
perspective most people won't be
interested in that so what happened
after after the event
I I went I was at school and my uh you
know my kind of Ambitions I thought I
was going to be a involved in real
estate somehow because my my father was
involved in real estate so I ended up
going to to University to study real
estate no without a thing they had a
course I think I was in year two of
University and CB Richard Ellis who um
are the one of the big property
companies in the world came around to
all of the universities and said we're
looking for five people to go to China
and work for us and I ended up winning
one of those five spaces and going to
China which was the adventure was
extraordinary
the part where I sat in the office in
Shanghai
and and sort of waited for the day to
finish I just realized oh I don't know
if this is me I don't know if commercial
real estate is my thing I thought maybe
it was
and then I blew short long story short I
blew an interview at the end of my
University career like really blew it
badly
that was like my shot at a really great
job in real estate and when I blew that
interview
it made me I was able to not even I
didn't even have to be brave I was like
well they took the opportunity of me
doing something here has been taken away
from me so I might as well go and start
my own thing or go and try coaching try
and public speak more
just a quick announcement from one of
our sponsors and we'll get right back to
the episode and this episode is brought
to you by Heights Heights is a brain
care smart supplement that I've been
taking every morning for the last 12
months I love it so much that I actually
became friends with the founder Dan who
we actually had on season one of the
Deep dive podcast we also have an
interview this season with
neuroscientist and psychiatrist Dr Tara
swart who's the chief science officer of
heights and I like the product so much
that I actually became an angel investor
in the company it's great everything
they do is completely evidence-based so
on their website they've got a list of
all 20-something micronutrients that
they've got in these two capsules along
with links to all of the various
scientific papers and consensuses on why
these sorts of nutrients are good for
you and why they've got them at the
appropriate dosing which they have in
the capsules in the capsules it's super
easy to sign up you just go on the
website which is linked in the show
notes and in the video description and
you put in your address and they send
you one of these little boxes of pills
every month or every quarter now I sign
up to the quarterly subscription so I
get three of these every three months
and the quarterly subscription is great
because a it's discounted from the
monthly subscription and B if you use
the coupon code Ali 15 ali15 at checkout
then you'll get an extra 15 off the
already discounted price of the
quarterly subscription now obviously
it's ideal if you can actually get all
these micronutrients from your diet that
would be the gold standard but as
studies show 99 of us in the Western
World don't in fact have the absolutely
perfect gold standard Mediterranean diet
I certainly don't I eat a lot of
takeaways and so these two capsules just
two capsules Every Morning has my base
is covered and it's a lot easier to take
just two little capsules with water than
it is to try and drown green sludge or
whatever else other other companies have
in the market that kind of does the same
thing so anyway thank you so much
Heights for sponsoring this episode and
let's get right back to the podcast you
would have graduated university around
age 21 but you said you'd been doing
public speak like what was the public
speaking on I had a couple of years
before that I think I was about 17 16 17
at the time I went to DAL Carnegie's
offices in London I remember going to
one of their free events
and just being fat you know so into the
book and when I heard there was like a
free event in London for Dale Carnegie I
was like I'm gonna go which I always
tell people I'm like I I was excited you
know this wasn't me at a certain point
who when I want to go and sell courses I
want to go and for me I was
my I that was me I was the guy in the
gym yeah yeah it was my was I was
excited about so I was just excited to
learn
and I went to one of these free uh
events and I was
at the time
it's not that the event was probably
great but I had come off the back of
like seeing Tony Robbins live yeah and I
was like oh it was so sort of deflating
for me and I remember going to their
offices in London
and asking them for a job basically and
the guy was very diplomatic uh who he
was sort of that I think it was the MD
there and he said well you know we um
you know we could you know have you come
here and work to become a speaker but it
would be a long long path and he used
the phrase I think we would just slow
you down you're a man on a mission and I
think we would slow you down which was
very very Dale Carnegie of him he knew
what he was doing and I in my head I
didn't hear a rejection uh I didn't hear
someone saying you're way too young to
be involved with us and you've got
nothing to offer us right now I just
heard yeah he's right they would slow me
down and so I left and
um and continued on my path but there
was a guy in London who was doing men's
workshops
and he needed help and that was useful
for me because around I think I was 18
at the time he I went to him and I was
like look you I'll come and just help
you set up the event I'll help you just
if I can even just do a little warm-up
for you or whatever I'll do whatever you
want it was you know I always imagine
I'm not making any comparison here but
you know like when I read stories about
the Beatles I I read like they just went
touring around these tiny venues and
would play and play and play all these
small small events
and that was really what made them so
seasoned when later on they had all of
this uh you know Fame
for me I was really really I count
myself so lucky that at that age I found
a way that was very very low stakes to
go and cut my teeth on public speaking
and so there would just be you know four
or five guys sat around and at a very
young age
I sort of started being given what I saw
as air time yeah you know it was and
again it was probably that the people
that were already working there just
wanted to break
they wanted to go on lunch and they were
like if this if this young dude wants to
get up and talk for an hour that gives
us time to go and chill so that was what
I started to do so the the few a few
Reflections on that so that's that's so
interesting because
I mean there's a lot of
um young people who are actually a lot
of people in my audience who are super
into like personal development and stuff
like that's the whole Arc of my my
YouTube channel essentially and I always
get emails from people who are teenagers
being like hey I've just read uh you
know the magic thinking big or how to
win friends and influence people or any
one of the 100 different best-selling uh
personal development books and yet the I
guess for you you had that interest and
you took the next step of being like let
me actually go to some of these events
let me cold email the people who are on
these events and like volunteer my
services for no money to just try and
get some more experience there yeah I
like I don't think I thought of this uh
at the time consciously but I've always
used the phrase
since thinking about it consciously
stuff leads to stuff
I I think there is something about that
phrase that encapsulates so much of how
all of us come to do something that we
never thought we would be doing or that
we an opportunity we never thought we'd
have
um you know even today when you say oh
was that the kind of old pickup artist
type stuff there's a part of me that
goes yeah you know like yeah it was but
the truth is
at the time I I was willing to to be
Scrappy I was willing to you know it was
like I don't I sometimes I think we so
over judge every next move yeah
um I remember giving I remember a friend
of mine
um
who I once who who's a an amazing
animator and I once had an animation
project that I needed for my business
and you know I said to him do you want
to do this
and at the time he he said something
like
um you know I I don't know if that's the
kind of work I want to do I want to you
know and I I remember at the time by the
way I'm not saying I'm right but at the
time I remember thinking
you've made it the parameters so kind of
rigid for what kind of work you are
prepared to do that I worry that you're
not because doing this thing for me
might land you this thing over here that
that you never would have got otherwise
it might give you a level of exposure
and
I'm I'm maybe not right about that I
don't know I you know there might be
people who have much more defined
parameters for what they're willing to
do but for me
as long as it didn't genuinely
compromise
my like core core values
I always look to everything like it's
stuff leads to stuff I you know I do do
I want to be associated with kind of
pickup artists and all of that no
but but is there an opportunity here for
me to do something is Dale Carnegie
letting me on the stage
no you know is anyone with any
credibility who's saying to this 18 year
old yeah get on stage talk to our
audience no so in that situation it it
happened to be something that allowed me
to
to learn something an age it allow me to
get my 10 000 hours way before most
people would ever get the opportunity I
wanna I wanna go back to the the journey
um so you're sort of 18 19 years old you
call email this guy who's running
workshops for men and he's like all
right cool you can be on stage for an
hour yeah or whatever like what what
kind of stuff are you talking about as
an 18 19 year old well I I was probably
at the time I parroting
what I had read and heard from other
people and filtering it through this
kind of
you know dating Centric lens
that to some people hearing it who
hadn't done my reading felt original or
felt like it was sort of groundbreaking
but I was you know borrowing or stealing
from
all these sort of influences that I had
read about
and
and you know I I think one of the
biggest things I talked about two two
things I talked about a lot one was the
anxiety of the approach and the other
was the deeper confidence that underpins
um us feeling like it's not that the
world has crashed down if it goes wrong
to say that I had figured those things
out would have been a lie
but the one thing at the time the one
bit of credibility I had was that I was
doing what I was asking them to do
that that getting over your fear and
actually doing the thing whether it was
in public speaking or whether it was in
approaching a girl at the time I really
was living that so I felt I always felt
like well as long as I'm one step ahead
yep I can always give you something
um but I you know like I said at the
time I was I was exploring all these
worlds myself I didn't realize how many
you know when I look back now I sort of
cringe at how much I thought I you know
I I it's very cringe-worthy in fact but
you know I all the later problems would
would come in my 20s when I realized I
hadn't figured out any of my stuff yet
and there was all this processing I had
to do of my own life but but the the
taking a risk part
I felt like I can do someone could be 40
years old
and if they're not taking a risk that
I'm taking then I I can at least help
them take that risk if nothing else I
might not be able to help them get over
their deeper issues but if I can get
them over the ledge of this thing that
they've never done that will be progress
for them and it was at the time it was
just a quick little break before we get
right back to the episode and that's to
let you know that this episode is very
kindly brought to you by short form
short form is the world's best service
for reading summaries of books but it's
more than just book summaries what short
form does is it basically creates a sort
of study guide for tons and tons of
different non-fiction books from all
sorts of genres from self-help and
personal development to money and
history and philosophy it's just got
loads of really interesting books and
they summarize them firstly with a cool
one-page summary but then they also have
chapter by chapter outlines of each book
and in between the chapter summaries
they also have kind of interactive
exercise sections where you can take the
insights from the book and actually
apply them to your life and the other
cool thing about short form is that if
for example an author says something
that is a little bit Dodge or that has
been debunked or kind of disagreed with
with another author then the short form
team will write a note saying that hey
you know this person said this thing
about this topic but actually that has
been debunked by this other person and
they'll bring in another source and so
it's not just a way of getting summaries
of books it's also a way of expanding
your understanding of the genre as a
whole for example One summary I read in
short form recently is a summary of
super fans by my friend Pat Flynn now I
read super fans ages ago like years ago
when it first came out this was before I
knew Pat personally and it was really
great as a guide on how to kind of build
an audience that knows likes and trusts
you but it's been a while since I read
the book and I don't want to read the
whole book in its entirety sorry Pat and
so I Revisited the insights from short
form and got a lot of value out of that
as well but I found it super helpful to
look at the short form summary to
revisit some of the ideas in the book
and this kind of tends to be how I use
short form either I use it as a way of
deciding whether I want to read a book
if it's new to me or I use it as a way
of revisiting ideas from books I've
already read so if any of that stands up
your street and you two would like to
try out the world's best service for
summarizing books then head over to
short form dot com forward slash deep
dive and firstly that will give you a
completely free five-day trial where you
can try it out and see if you like it
and it will also give you 20 off the
annual premium subscription which is the
thing that I personally subscribe to so
thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode when I first
started teaching my part-time YouTuber
Academy just sort of teaching people how
to do YouTube I was so surprised that
like 95 of our students are older than I
am and we're having issues with
confidence and putting themselves out
there on camera and initially I had so
much impossible I'm like what the hell
could I possibly hope to teach a 45 year
old executive at McKinsey or something
like that I was like oh this person
struggles to put themselves now in front
of a camera I've been doing this for
years okay I can teach something yeah
and it felt very much this this weird
weird sense of damn like real adults
actually struggle with these things as
well yeah I don't know if you had that
kind of experience at all no I
you know what's funny is I now look at
both of our arguments there and I'm like
yeah but maybe there are
like maybe they've just always been
afraid but also the older you get the
more you develop new fears the more you
have sort of things to lose that you
didn't have when to lose when you were
21 or I I had to go in in a helicopter
recently which I say not as any kind of
a humbleback I didn't want to go I
didn't I I don't I I was with a group of
people that really wanted to have this
experience and I'm not
I had a bad experience in a plane
that a couple of years back that gave me
a sort of a bit of a fear of flying I I
can't it's not a fear I'm able to
indulge because I have to go I have to
fly all the time but I do not enjoy
flying the way I used to
um it makes me anxious like take off and
landing and turbulence and all of that
and uh and I had to you know that was
with a group of friends who really
wanted to do this helicopter experience
and I I said yes because I was like I
don't want to be the guy that stops
everyone from doing something fun on a
trip that I'm part of I'm just going to
go along with it
but I can tell you now that 21 year old
me wouldn't have had a problem with that
at all
it would have been fine and would have
been like yeah let's do that that sounds
great
I'm now 35 and
um it's not such a enjoyable experience
for me or I get anxiety that I didn't
have before
I I that makes me just you know when
you're dealing with older people you
what you don't know is what they've
encountered in their lives when I was
you know 25 and working with a woman who
was 50.
and getting into dating again after a
20-year marriage had fallen apart
my saying oh you just have to get over
your fear by doing this and this and
this it's
I may be right
but
I don't understand what she's been
through I don't understand what it's
like to have been out of the dating game
for 20 years
and everything changed in that time
and that you know she's starting it
truly starting again at an an age that
she can't relate to dating at yeah
because the last time she was dating she
was 30. and you know so
so you kind of you can know something
but not know you you know you may have
been in the same I'm guessing that there
may have been situations where you might
have been working with someone who is
afraid to get on camera
but if there are 45 year old who's led a
whole life
and developed many deep Connections in
their life and they've had a an image
that's been cultivated over 25 years of
adult life
and a career where everyone sees them in
a certain way is much heart that fear of
like
making a video I'm putting out there in
the public is a very different thing for
someone like that than it is for a 25
year old who's
identity is five years old
in terms of their Adult Career Identity
or seven if you count University
so you know I I feel like those are some
of the things that you don't consider at
a certain age even when you're saying
the right things like I did it I
remember when I first moved to Beverly
Hills uh not the Beverly Hills to La I I
remember
having
this thought that would be fun to film a
video in Beverly Hills I thought it was
so cool I was like I just got to La I'm
gonna do a video in front of the Beverly
Hills Sign and I went over there and I
shot this video and there was this guy
who was watching me the whole time
and it made me a bit self-conscious when
I was filming the video it's always that
funny thing isn't it you could make a
video for hundreds of thousands or
millions of people and yet someone's
actually watching you film it and you're
like a person
that guy came up to me at the end of
this video and the video by the way was
the three tips to like overcoming
heartbreak something like that
this guy came up to me at the end of the
video and he goes
you've never been heartbroken have you
and at the time I was not I was like
annoyed you know when someone feels like
someone's caught you out deep down there
like needling at something and I was
like how dare he you know I'm here
making my video and doing he doesn't
know me and the truth was he sensed he
knew something
he knew from the way I was talking
that I had not truly had my heart broken
he could sense that
and so that was where that comment came
from for him and even though I was like
had this righteous indignation
he was right
now I've since corrected that I I have
uh corrected that hole in my resume
but at the time
uh I hadn't not really I'd experienced
what I thought was heartbreak
but
there's heartbreaking there's heartbreak
and anyone who's been truly heartbroken
knows the difference
and knows that making a video
that's called the three tips to getting
over heartbreak is sort of absurd and
it's a in its very
premise right because going when you're
in heartbreak you're not going to get
out of it with three tips you are a
walking
zombie who it appears numb on the
outside but on the inside feels like
you're dying
and unless you've been through it you
don't know how to truly acknowledge that
for somebody else and I think that for
young content creators
and I count myself still among them
we all have to be really careful
and the younger you are the more careful
you have to be
that you never fall into the Trap of of
trying to know it all or pretending that
you know it all and making that one of
your masks I did it I fell into that
trap when I was starting out I really
tried to appear like there was no
question I couldn't answer
and it and it was a weakness because
it's not true smarter wiser people can
smell it yeah and you'll lose
opportunities because of it
and I said to someone I care about and
love very much who's who's kind of go-to
reflexive phrases yeah I know
you know when you're talking to someone
and halfway through the sentence before
you've even finished they go yeah I know
it's the worst phrase in the world it's
very annoying and when you get someone
like that you sort of quite quickly
decide that teaching them anything isn't
Fun
it's not enjoyable
and that it doesn't feel good to have a
conversation because they don't they
don't make you know they they already
know okay you already know I won't say
it
and so you really stop learning when you
when you use that phrase
I wasn't someone who said yeah I know
but I certainly acted in my work like I
knew
much more than I did and I've since then
really
really enjoyed being someone who doesn't
know
so where
you're a young Matthew you're like 19
doing these workshops where you're kind
of helping people overcome approach
anxiety and things like that
what happens next in the sort of public
speaking Arc I I started doing small
events for women
um because I I had this thought that
well
it'd be nice to do something out of the
men's area I was looking for a change
and
I was I think I was just I was just
leaving University
and in that
that's that crossroads of am I now gonna
go and
work for a company or am I going to do
my own thing
and
I started
uh I started just putting I put together
a little website and was like well maybe
we'll just do some small stuff for women
I actually you know what I did in the
beginning I just
said if you email me a question I'll
answer it like if you write in I had a
website and it was it was for women and
I just said if you email me a question
I'll I'll answer it and that for me was
like research like what what problems
are people having in this area
okay do I know anything that can help
how
how did you go straight for like from
I'm helping men do approach anxiety too
I'm not going to give dating advice to
women that that seems like a Chasm that
I wouldn't think of
well I originally I thought
here's what it was I read a book
a very well-known book for women at the
time which one it was called the rules
oh yeah I read that a couple years ago
it's super interesting very interesting
and I you know I'm I don't
at the time there was some there was
something in there that I read and I
went
that's not true for me
you know there was a there was a
particular sentence or a chapter I can't
remember but it basically said if a guy
isn't coming over to you
then he's he's not interested
they'll forgive me if I've misphrased
that but I it got that was the kind of
tone of it and I I remember thinking
everything about my life has said that
the opposite is true Yeah the more
interested I am yeah the less likely
yeah I remember I remember reading that
kind of stuff and thinking oh this is I
just specifically wow this is you know I
literally have spent my life doing the
opposite of that
and that kind of sparked something in me
because I thought
I wonder how many women
are only ever meeting the loudest guy in
the room yeah the one with them with the
confidence to approach them whereas the
other 90 of dudes are just like a game
of written off either as not interested
or as
um
cowards yeah
you know you if you don't and I I would
hear women say stuff like that when you
know if you don't if you don't have the
kind of stones to approach me yeah then
I don't want to know you I don't know if
I yeah I want you anyway and I felt very
rejected by that because I was like but
I'm like a good human being you know I I
would be great for for someone in a
relationship I have a lot to give I you
know
and the idea that I would be measured
simply on that moment that I decided not
to go and interrupt someone's
conversation and sort of say hey
um based on nothing at all really yeah
other than the fact that I think you're
pretty I'd like to get to know you which
is a problem for men
from the outset is you don't want to be
superficial
you want to form a connection that says
hey I'm not just some creep I'm not just
objectifying people I actually want to
get to know you but the very reason
you've gone over to someone in the first
place is because you find them
attractive that's a hard thing to yeah
it's a big sort of cognitive dissonance
there where you sort of yeah you you
know why have you come over to me yeah
because I've felt like what you did in
the last year at work was really
impressive and you don't know that so
that's for for the most part is what you
have to go on is someone's at best you
could say someone's energy if you really
wanted to make it about something that
didn't feel as superficial as looks
something about your style exactly your
aura yeah but but I um
I started to think well
there's actually a lot of really amazing
guys out there
who aren't in the habit of racing up to
Every Woman they're attracted to how do
you get women Meeting those guys because
if you could just solve that problem you
actually are gonna you're gonna be
responsible for a hell of a lot of
relationships
and this was
pre-dating apps so dating apps
solved some of that problem because it
gave people an opportunity to approach
whoever they liked from the safety of a
screen which we know has its problems
too because you could do now all sorts
of things from the safety of being
behind the screen
but I
before dating apps I I figured well if I
can get women to be able to approach a
guy
that they wouldn't normally meet
because he's kind of hanging back and
just
you know doing his thing and he's not
the kind of guy that's running up to
everyone all the time
that will have been to some effect and
so I I started talking about this idea
of the handkerchief and I kind of became
known for the videos of you talking
about handkerchief and that was one of
the handkerchief for people who are a
metaphor that that I started speaking
about very very early on where I it was
my way of telling saying to women
you don't have to tell yourself this
story that if you approach someone
you're somehow going against your
nature or what's or the way things are
supposed to be if that's even true but a
lot of women have been conditioned to
believe that the guy is supposed to make
the move and I would say well if you
think that's old-fashioned you don't
know what old-fashioned really is
a hundred years ago a woman might walk
past a guy find him attractive and
inadvertently drop her handkerchief in
front of him he would see it pick it up
and think this is an extraordinary
opportunity to be a man and he'd take it
over to and he'd say Madam you dropped
this and and she would say did I and
they would now have a conversation he
may have felt he was being the proactive
one by ah I'm gonna pick up this
handkerchief and walk it back over to
her what a great opportunity to make a
move
but she had initiated that move she was
the one who made the move she just made
him feel like he was the one making the
move and that there's some there seemed
to be something very interesting in that
to me the okay regardless of whether you
think women can or can't make the move
of course they can
but it almost what I was getting at is
it doesn't matter
what you believe
if I can give you a way to be proactive
that kind of feels like it's a bit under
the radar then I'm going to get even
people who feel like it's not my job to
make the move I'm even gonna get them
being proactive in ways they haven't
before so I started translating the idea
of the handkerchief into practical
things that women could do and it was
the results were really stunning because
women suddenly felt like
they had choice
that they never had before they were
able to get dates
and exchange numbers with people and
create activity in their love life
and they hadn't been doing that for some
for some people for years
they had never had much opportunity in
their love lives and all of a sudden not
only were they being proactive and
creating opportunity but they were doing
it with people they were attracted to
they would be they were choosing instead
of being chosen which was very cool so
what are the what are the modern day
handkerchiefs just on that on that topic
I so there was a a book that talked
about the
the idea that likability
was affected by our ability to do
someone a favor
um now what the study showed was not the
obvious that if we do someone a favor
they'll like us more is that if we do
someone a favor we like them more
as long as the favors not onerous it
can't be something difficult but if
we're able to do a small act a small
favor for somebody we actually like them
more
and I started looking at that in the
context of the handkerchief and I
thought that sort of feels like it
applies there especially it's almost
feels more potent in the direction of
man to woman because a lot of guys have
this sort of you know I want to be
needed I want to feel like I'm able to
do something for a woman I want to feel
necessary which is a big problem right
now in dating because men are feeling
less and less necessary uh and you know
everyone's trying to figure out their
place right now in the world which is I
find really fascinating uh the the kind
of rules are being Rewritten but
what I saw is with the handkerchief is
oh a guy
has an opportunity to kind of perform a
small favor which is giving the
handkerchief back so then I said well
what's an equivalent of of them there's
all sorts of little ways you can ask for
a favor you could say excuse me would
you just watch my jacket for a second
while I use the restroom which could be
done
in a coffee shop in the daytime
I just need to use the restroom when you
watch my jacket for a second
um or you know I always like the start
of the phrase being I could you know
could I get your help with something or
I could really use your help with
something could you watch my jacket for
a second while I go to the bathroom do
you know anywhere good around here for X
what did you order that looks really
good I you know it
these are all very small things but they
give someone the opportunity to do a
small Act of service for us what I also
like about it is it breaks the ice in a
way that doesn't feel like breaking the
ice so when you come back from the
bathroom and you say thanks so much for
for watching my jacket
if you then say how's your day going
anyway
um or you know it looks like that but
that book looks really interesting or
whatever
you feel like you're already starting at
30 mile an hour
versus if you were just there and you
turned to someone and went how's your
day going yeah that's a bit weird now
you can do it but
it's a lot of people feel like they need
that like 30 miles an hour to get going
so that became my version for people of
dropping the handkerchief is ask a very
small and easy favor of someone
and then allow that to be the bridge to
a natural conversation nice
yeah that I guess is fairly us somewhat
similar to the whole uh indirect openers
that guys will often use around like hey
you know can you tell me where the
nearest coffee shop is or something like
that I'm new here it's just a way of
prompting a conversation in a way that's
not something like hi I thought you were
pretty and I wanted to talk to you 100
takes a large amount of almost too much
confidence
yes and you know there's how you they
can make someone else feel awkward and
there's all sorts of things I I think
for anyone else for anyone out there man
or woman one of the things if if this is
the kind of content you're interested in
that I have found most helpful in my
life
is something I call two hit Theory which
is the idea that
how when you go out into any environment
you have to be someone who's easy to
talk to you focusing on approachability
is as important as focusing on how to
approach
and
what a lot of us do is we go into an
environment we wait until we see someone
that we're attracted to
and then we obsess over what the hell we
would say if we tried to talk to that
person and now we spend the whole
time that we're there becoming more and
more nervous as the stakes get higher
and higher and we start to imagine how
wonderful this person is that we think
is attractive and how lucky the person
is that gets them and all the thing the
qualities about them that we wouldn't
admire if we got to know them they
become something they become this
projection that is so removed
from what we actually know about them
right now which is we just saw an
attractive person that's it
two hit theory is when you go into a
room
the first hit as it were is
small interactions with people
it might literally be like that looks
really good
because someone ordered a plate of food
and you're like that looks great that's
a that's a hit that's an interaction
it might be
um walking up to the bar or the counter
and someone's next to you and you're
like hey how's it going
like a moment you don't remove the
intention there's no intention doesn't
need to go anywhere it doesn't need to
be a conversation nothing just a moment
and you do that with more people than
you normally would you have these little
hits
now what to me is really really powerful
about this is such an understated thing
but what's really powerful about it is
most people when they go to any
environment they're either alone or
they're with one or two friends
outside of those one or two friends
who's the person they're most likely
to talk to at some point during the
evening at some point during that event
they're going to talk to the the most
approachable person they're going to
talk to the person they've already had
some small interaction with that became
a kind of green light for a natural or
organic Exchange
if you've had the natural or organic
exchange with someone it's weird to say
but you're their third best friend in
the room yeah
and if you go around being the third
best friend of everybody who came with
two people
just because you are a little bit more
approachable than everybody else then
it's you're gonna find that a some
interactions just gravitate back to you
an hour later or two hours later
B even if you're the one who initiates
you already have that initial
interaction to go by yeah
and the fact that that initial
interaction didn't come with you
like there's always something about
someone coming over to you and talking
to you for the first time and then sort
of standing there and facing you as
they're talking to you and you're almost
unable to process whether you find them
attractive or whether you uh want are
interested in what they have to say
because you're so busy worrying about
are they ever going to leave yeah
so when someone does this to hit theory
that that first thing that first
interaction you have with people
helps them also they've already
recognized that you're not the kind of
person that needs them yep
you left the first time
so now when you speak to someone it the
stakes feel much lower for something
like safety as well like you don't feel
as if yeah they're just not going to
leave they're just going oh God it's
like getting on you know what it's like
you know when you get on a plane and the
person next to you
starts talking to you
now maybe you're in a sociable mood and
that's awesome
or maybe
like me you sort of have a whole bunch
of things that you're kind of excited to
do on that plane one of them being
nothing yeah
and there's a part of you and it's not
the best part of you but there's a part
of you that instantly goes oh no am I
next to a talker is this now gonna be my
flight
when someone says something
for 30 seconds
and then says well it's nice to meet you
and then goes back to their book you go
oh yeah okay and then it's almost like
you wouldn't mind if you ended up
talking to them more because you go oh
this person's chill they've got their
own thing going on that's I I liken it
to that and too often when we're in the
mode of I want to get something
we forget to communicate to other people
that we don't actually need them
just a quick note from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and this episode is very kindly
brought to you by skillshare if you
haven't heard by now skillshare is one
of the world's leading platforms for
online classes for online education
they've got thousands and thousands of
classes on all sorts of topics from
business entrepreneurship lifestyle
design cooking interior design loads of
stuff and very excitingly I have
actually been teaching on skillshare
since 2019 and I've got 13 classes on
skillshare yes 13 classes and you can
access all of them completely free of
charge by going to skillshare.com
forward slash Deep dive and that link
will give you a free one month trial to
skillshare during which you can watch
any and all of my classes now if for
example you happen to be a student or
you're just interested in lifelong
learning then I've got two classes on
skillshare that I've taught that you
might be interested in the first one is
my how to study for exams evidence-based
tips study class and that basically
compiles every single thing that I've
ever learned and that the research shows
on what are the most evidence-based and
effective ways of studying for your
exams and I also have a class on
skillshare around how to use Anki which
is the world's most popular flashcard
app which you can use for studying for
exams but also for learning languages
for learning music theory things like
that and loads of people have taken that
class and said that that class was so
good that they would have literally paid
hundreds of dollars for it but you get
it completely for free on skillshare by
going to skillshare.com forward slash
Deep dive after your trial is over you
can choose to continue the subscription
if you like and you can access the
thousands of classes skillshare house
from other teachers including people
that I know people I'm friends with like
Thomas Frank and Nathaniel Drew but yeah
the main reason to check out skillshare
of course is that you want to check out
my classes if you want to learn about
productivity and video editing and
youtubing and even cooking so head over
to skillshare.com forward slash Deep
dive and thank you so much skillshare
for sponsoring this episode yeah this is
something that um Mark Manson's book
models which I'm sure you've read uh
talks about a lot it hasn't oh you
haven't is this his new one uh no this
is his really old one this is from like
2011 back when he was a pickup kind of
guy so this was before the satellite
this was before the satellite before he
became like a general president no I
never read it oh it's by far the best
book I've ever read in the pickup genre
and it's really all about this idea of
embracing your own vulnerability and
being non-needy and it's it was sort of
when I came across that sort of sort of
like the end to a lot of the other BS
that was out there in the sort of pickup
genre and then this book was really
about genuinely men's personal
development and it's okay to go up to
people it's okay to show vulnerability
emotional intelligence it was just like
great great on all fronts
um but his like a big part of his his
thesis was that look you know the thing
you want to sub communicate is
non-neediness that you don't need this
person and therefore become the sort of
guy who has your own stuff going on and
therefore you genuinely don't need this
person and so when you're having a
conversation with someone there's no
strings attached to that conversation
you're not like uh your your self-worth
is not dependent on the way that they
interact with you yeah and his his
theory in the book which I think is
broadly true and I'd love to get your
take on this is that people can tell
over people have a very fine YouTube
radar for like neediness and when
someone seems a little bit like too
approval seeking or something like that
um and I I suspect that's a big part of
you know when generally women describe
generally men as creeps it's like
there's something about the interaction
that gives them that kind of that kind
of message yeah I think that's
absolutely true I I talk about the
um
there being a kind of a formula and I
don't mean this crudely I I just mean
there are certain components to deep and
Lasting attraction
you have chemistry
um
perceived value
perceived challenge
and connection
the reason I like this model is because
when you look at this you can usually
see you can sort of self-diagnose
where something may be going wrong
chemistry is interesting because there's
certain there's a certain intangible
there and an unknown there and not we
certainly can't control all of it but we
can control some of it you know with the
way the way that we look how well we
take care of ourselves the way we move
importantly is a big factor in chemistry
which is why you can sometimes see
someone in photos and think they're
really attractive and then you meet them
in real life and you kind of go Oh weird
I don't feel the same way it's also why
you can get back from a date and and say
oh my God I just had this amazing date
with this incredibly hot person and if
you show pictures of that person to your
friends they're like okay yeah
I guess you know because you you were
there yeah you were there you saw how
they move how they smile how they
gesture how they their micro Expressions
so there's certainly things we can do to
affect chemistry and obviously you can
create tension too which is a big factor
in chemistry in chemistry then there's
perceived value and perceived value is
all these things that that we are and do
that bring value to the table it might
be our personality uh it might be the
things that we're good at in life it
might be our life the life that we've
built
um can sometimes be our friends and
family you know sometimes you meet
someone's friends and family and you go
whoa this is what a life this is to come
into they have an amazing group of
people around them so much love so much
so there's a lot of ways for perceived
value to to manifest itself then there's
perceived challenge
and the interesting thing about
perceived value is it goes down
regardless of how many things are in
that category
if there's no perceived Challenge
and perceived challenge is not uh
the kind of
I don't know a typical way of thinking
about it I guess would be like hard to
get
it's not that's a cheap way to create
challenge because the problem with hard
to get is you can't keep it up forever
the moment you oh God yeah
if someone's if your attraction was
built around the getting then you can't
sustain it
but if
the the real beautiful sustainable way
to create challenge is for there to be
uh for your value to have a price
okay what do you mean
that your value doesn't come for free
your value is something that has to be
earned
by the someone showing up in the way
you're prepared to show up by someone
being prepared to make the kind of
sacrifices you're prepared to make for
someone
um by someone giving to you on a level
that you're willing to give respecting
you on a level that that you respect
them
um
and also not giving someone too much
credit too quickly
that's a a big problem when we come from
a needy place when we come from a place
of insecurity we start giving people
credit they don't deserve yet
I just met them I just had the most
amazing date with the most amazing
person oh my God they're incredible
based on what
based on how on what basis what
information could you have possibly got
on one date
that enables you to say this
you
you have been seduced by a kind of charm
Charisma maybe the fact that you did
something really fun on the day the fact
that they made you laugh a lot the fact
that they told stories about their past
that made them relatable or sympathetic
or seem really authentic all of that is
great I'm not I'm not saying be
inherently suspicious I'm saying
you don't know yeah
you don't know so on what basis are you
giving them all of this value already
based on projection
and based on insecurity this immediate
putting them on a pedestal and putting
yourself down here and when someone
smells that
they don't see an equal anymore
and that's that's what I mean when I say
challenge I don't mean artificially
constructing
games or Hoops for people to jump
through
I mean that the the criteria you have
for someone has to be real yeah it has
to be real like
it's you and I met today for the first
time
really enjoying our conversation hope
you are too absolutely you know but we
don't know each other yet as friends you
don't know if I'd be reliable if you
needed something you don't know if I
would show up to support you if
something went wrong in your life you
don't know you don't know any of that
so
you know it would be dangerous to go
away and make a an assessment on how
great of a friend I would be yep based
on this exchange it what what you would
hope in an organic situation is that you
and I go
this was really really fun we got on
really well this was a great
conversation I would like to get to know
this guy better that would be like it'd
be really cool if we could hang out
outside of the podcast
but it's not I have to be friends with
with Ali you know like we I have to
because he's a he's an amazing guy you
know like yeah that's that now that's
projection that's dangerous because I'm
basing that on the fact that you're
clearly outwardly a very impressive
human and what you've achieved what
you've done is very impressive and you
seem to have had a really amazing kind
of impact on a lot of people and those
are all amazing things those are amazing
things in their own right
it's not about devaluing those
but
I have no idea what your value would be
as a friend
until we try being friends
and the mistake people make in dating
commonly
is they look at someone's
stats
how Charming were they how charismatic
were they how successful are they
um you know where are they in their life
what kind of person do they seem to be
but none of that exists in relation to
to you
that's all just you admiring
what this person has or is
but none of it says this person is going
to be a great boyfriend or a great
girlfriend none of it says they're going
to be loyal none of it says they're
going to be reliable none of it says
they're going to be a great teammate all
it says is this person seems on these
metrics
to be attractive and in any relationship
you have to go through for for in terms
of importance you have to go through
four stages
one is admiration that's just where I
can see someone and admire them from
either up close or far wow this person's
pretty impressive and attractive not
very important in the stages not
important yeah necessary but not
important yep
then there's uh a connection
or chemistry you both you need you know
that's the next stage of do we feel
connected to each other and is there a
kind of chemistry all right now it's
slightly more important because now it
becomes Mutual now it's not just me
admiring you it's oh there's something
between us yeah
not important
because necessary yeah but not important
how many people have ruined their lives
over the fact that they had chemistry
with someone even when that person was a
terrible partner a terrible person to
base their their decisions on
the next stage is uh commitment
okay I admire you we have mutual
chemistry and connection and we're both
actually saying yes to each other I deal
with people every day where they have
this stage
but that person isn't saying yes
they're saying yeah I'd like to see you
this Friday
at 11 o'clock
but they're not saying yes to an actual
relationship
so you need commitment to go to the next
stage of importance but many people are
treating something like it has total
importance even though they're only at
the second stage so you need a yes you
need commitment
now you would say if you've got that
that's the most important thing you can
have you've got someone you admire
you've got someone you have a connection
with in chemistry and you've got someone
who is committed
it would seem like that was everything
but that kind of idea is it Virgil would
love conquers all love does not conquer
all
two people saying yes to each other
doesn't
make for a long-term relationship you
also have to have the fourth stage of
importance which is compatibility yeah
are you actually compatible because if
you're not
you can say yes I want to be with you
yes I'm committed
but that lack of compatibility will show
up in ways that will make both of you
miserable well what do you mean by
compatibility it could be anything it
could be my idea of a good time is
staying home watching movies and yours
is constantly traveling around the world
it could be your idea of a good time is
going out and drinking and doing drugs
and I don't want to live that life and
we've both said yes to each other
but
the you know our idea of what is a good
life is completely different or our idea
of loyalty is completely different your
idea of loyalty is that I don't have sex
with anyone my idea of loyalty is that
you don't emotionally cheat on me
in the texts you send yep you know that
we've both said yes to each other we
have admiration connection commitment
and yet I am miserable because of what
your definition of loyalty is
so compatibility is do we both want to
live the same kind of life and and do
our values line up and do we both have
the same idea two people can say I value
kindness but we can have very different
standards
for what kindness actually means
so
without that stage so many things go
wrong my
what what I mean to say with all of this
is that
we lose our value in dating
when we stop paying attention
to the appropriate level of importance
at different stages
if you
take stage two
I found someone I have a connection with
as the be-all Endor and the thing that
you
martyr yourself in service of
you lose all your value
you you are now the person who spends a
lifetime uh accepting really poor
treatment from someone because every
time you see them it's amazing you don't
understand when we're together it's so
good it's so incredible they're so there
for me that the sex is amazing the
chemistry is amazing we have such
amazing conversations
what's the problem I haven't heard from
them in two weeks
but Matt you don't understand the
connection is incredible you don't know
like this this is really important to me
why
why because you you have miscalculated
the value of stage two and when you do
that you lose your value because someone
realizes your value what you're willing
to give has no price
it's free it does not need to be earned
so your perceived challenge
drops and when you're perceived when
there's no challenge to you when someone
realizes your value has no price
then you lose respect and you and you
end up losing real value as a result
which is crazy but I know it all sounds
kind of heady but it
you know it really this stuff is real
whether you whether when someone
there'll be people listening to this uh
guarantee there'll be someone in the
comments
who says oh does it all need to be so
difficult can't you just be yourself and
the answer is no
because you may not be doing the things
that make you confident or that show
your real value you shouldn't be uh
someone you're not
but people Define being themselves as
holding on to all of their
the things that make them make bad
decisions or that make them uh their
trauma or the things that they haven't
healed or the things that make them
chase after someone who will ruin their
life that's not being yourself that's
that's not healing that's not doing the
things that are necessary for you to
attract a much more quality version of
connection and love in your life so the
reason that I've geeked out on all of
this stuff is because
the consequences of ignoring what I'm
saying
are a life of suffering and I have
watched it over and over again I have
watched women get to their 40s where
they just gave up 10 years of their life
to a guy that was never giving them what
they wanted was never on the same path
as them but they ignored it because they
valued the connection so much
well they valued the chemistry so much
or both and now their window for having
children of Their Own
has has gone
and the grief that comes after that is
profound
I I actually see that pain so when
someone in the comment says oh you don't
need to do all of this you don't need to
think about all of this it's the same as
someone saying
no one needs therapy
no one needs to work on themselves just
do you
okay
okay to then do that I'm not that guy
I'm not someone who's saying all of this
to other people and they're not doing it
for myself you know I'm I'm on a path
myself I have a therapist I have coaches
I have people that help me I I and I
will continue to my whole life because
why my life gets better when I get
better
love it that's a great chemistry
connection perceived value perceived
challenge
um
is there a difference in Waiting or
anything and I get okay so I guess this
is a broader question
is there much difference between dating
advice for men and dating is about
advice for women because I feel like the
more
abstracted you get in dating advice the
more it feels like it applies to both
sexes genders whatever term we want to
use for that but also then there are
the the more uh non-politically correct
you go down the different genres of
men's dating advice and women's dating
advice the more polarizing it seems it's
like okay this is for men and this is
for women yeah so what like how do you
straddle that
somewhat dodgy ground of like yeah this
works for women this works for
um I think that you have to just be
honest
from uh an empirical perspective
about what men seem to struggle with and
what women seem to struggle with okay
you know what I mean there's a the
empirical perspective the empirical
perspective is is just really us a fancy
way of saying what seems true based on
what you actually experienced
um
and then acting on solving the real
problem the real thing that you're
seeing over and over again
I think that it's empirically true for a
lot of guys
more than it's true for a lot of women
that men struggle to be vulnerable now
women struggle to be vulnerable too
there's no doubt about that everyone
does
but
when it comes to uh let's say being
strong
and appearing strong an appearing
masculine appearing Alpha men struggle
to be vulnerable
because a lot of men maybe most have
learned that a huge part of their value
is tied up in how strong
of a man they are
how their ability to dominate their
ability to be the alpha of the pack
these are very this is very male
conditioned
language I'm not an anthropologist so I
have no I don't need to talk about
whether it's biologically programmed or
where it comes from whether it's
genuinely a part of us and always will
be or whether it's just societally
conditioned I don't need to be part of
that argument I just need to deal with
men the way they actually are today yeah
and a huge number of men are terrified
that if they display any weakness
a woman is going to run the other way
and she's going to go and date the alpha
of the pack
um
so you can in that you can just say Okay
regardless of whether we're the getting
into the details of how when different
men and women are biologically I think
you can just say men struggle with this
how do we get men to be
vulnerable
but in a way that allows them to still
feel attractive
or how do they search for someone how do
they how do men start instead of putting
stock in how many women find them
attractive which may no longer be the
best measure of
your happiness is figuring out how to be
attractive to the maximum number of
women
instead maybe it's helping men redefine
oh happiness isn't being attractive to
the maximum number of women attractive
is finding a woman
or a happiness rather is finding a woman
that really accepts you
with for everything that you struggle
with as well as everywhere that you're
naturally strong
and that real happiness is going to be
finding someone who can hold both parts
of you they they both celebrate where
you're amazing and strong and naturally
gifted and they also are able to
accept and truly see the parts of you
that are afraid the parts of you that
have trauma the parts of you that don't
feel like you match up
to other men or other situations or
whatever
that to me and by the way doesn't then
Define You by that you know doesn't I I
always remember a relationship where I
said something very vulnerable I I
talked about something that had made me
insecure that night
and it really felt like it was thrown
back in my face like it didn't go well
you know I'm a huge brene brown fan but
in that night I hated brene Brown I was
like
I was like I should never have said this
yeah I just I feel like I just lost all
attraction in that moment and when
you're afraid like that you get mad
because you're like I'm never doing that
again
but that would have been to learn the
wrong lesson
because the right lesson would be oh I
need to find someone that is is capable
of
of actually seeing this part of me and
understanding it and also
in seeing it and understanding it not
then labeling me as that
not saying well now that you've said
that I'm just going to stay with you and
I'm still going to love you but I'm
gonna see you as insecure yeah no I just
someone who says oh I see that part of
you
still a you're still a man to me you're
still like this I just understand that
sometimes you feel like this that is
that should be happiness
to men but
a lot of men have been conditioned to
believe that happiness is being
attractive to the maximum number of
women
and so what do men do what would I argue
is a very male problem
is men striving their whole lives to get
as much power and status and success and
money as possible
in order to achieve
being attractive to the maximum number
of women
and therefore being happy yep and so you
then see how you can spend a lifetime
getting it backwards
without the right advice but if I went
to a room full of women
I don't think anyone
could argue
that it would seem a bit odd if I went
into a room full of women and said
we need to talk about the fact that you
guys worked your whole lives to acquire
money and power and Status so that men
will like you
that would seem everyone would go I
think he walked into the wrong room yeah
you know so that
because empirically
we know that that would be a strange
message in that room but in a room full
of men it would be a very very necessary
message and it would do a lot for men's
happiness if they were able to truly
absorb that message
so what is what are some things that
women struggle with
well
if we were to stay on subject for that
yeah a lot of women struggle with
the the the opposite seeming to be true
that the more I achieve and the more
status I get and the more money I
acquire and the more I have it all
together
the more it seems I'm turning
people off the more it seems I'm
pushing people away or that people are
intimidated by me
and and I think that there is a very
interesting thing going on right now
where
everyone is everyone is trying to find
their feet again there's like a
recalibration happening because you
still have
you have a generation of women who are
being
now told hey like you can go and go and
do what you want to do like
go make something of yourself go go hard
for that promotion for that job start
that company do that thing and all of
that is amazing
but you still have a lot of men
who have been told or brought up on the
idea that your value
is your ability to
provide your value is your ability to
look after yep I mean I my mum
loves women hmm
my mom always wanted a girl she tried
three times she got three boys and then
she gave up she desperately wanted a
girl
but she's old school East End you know
for those of you that are not in London
you you know if you think of the
cockneys that's the East End my mum's
Old School East End
she was brought up to believe that as a
woman a guy should look after you
and so as her son she brought me up on
that idea you do this for her you don't
you dare let her pay
you if I find out you let her pay
there'll be murders
that's my mum
that my mum would see A girlfriend of
mine pick up a bag and be like don't let
don't worry Matthew pick up that bag
don't let her do that little thing yeah
she's too stoned look at her don't get
but get that bag for her that's my mum
so
I grew up with this idea that oh I I
need to I need to pay for everything I
need to make sure that I open the door
that I pick up the bags I do this that I
do that that's my that's my value
so what happens
if I come face to face with someone
who says I don't need you to carry my
bags hmm
which my fiance has done routinely I
heard her laugh over there when I said
that because she's we've literally had
this conversation where I'm like
like she'll be picking up something that
is legitimately heavy and I'll be like I
I've you know I I can do this just like
let me do it because I'm I can be you
this is an area where I could be useful
yeah
and she's sort of in those moments now
look truthfully if she really wants to
pick up the bag fine
that's on me to be okay with that but
she also knows and is empathetic enough
to understand that that's kind of a nice
moment for me to be useful
right
but if I came face to face with someone
who I and and I hadn't done the work
I've done
and I was in that old Paradigm of well
unless they let me pay for everything
and by the way that must mean that they
need to earn a lot less than me because
otherwise they don't need me to pay for
everything and all of this feels like a
bit of a farce so now I need to date
someone who earns a lot less than me so
that it makes sense for me to pay
everything yeah
and I need someone who is hasn't got as
much status in their work because I'm
supposed to be the one who's providing
and I need so it you can see how that
version of me could come up against
someone who
is has been taught go own it do your
thing build your life become successful
earn money build a company whatever and
those that would feel like an
incompatibility and she would say he's
just intimidated by me
and I would be going
I don't know what I'm needed for here
yeah and and so on the guy's side that's
a miscalculation because men now need to
learn that
there's there's a much more diverse
range of ways that you can provide value
in the context of a uh Team than in
those very two-dimensional ways
but men need to learn that and that's
hard it's hard that you're literally
asking men with that to ReDiscover what
their confidence is based on that's not
an that's a tough thing to do we're
talking years of work
to completely redefine what your worth
is and have it come from a deeper more
nutritional source
and and then on the other side
I think that and again I'm not an expert
in this but I've I've seen 15 years of
coaching literally hundreds of thousands
of women in person and millions online
I've watched as people kind of
it's it's almost like if someone says
I'm you know I don't need a guy for this
and I'm I'm good here and I'm good here
and I leave work and people are
intimidated by my energy and sometimes I
want to say look I'm not excusing guys
because everything I just said about
guys is true they've got a lot of
relearning to do or learning for the
first time
but hey don't don't forget it's actually
not that attractive for you to have this
energy all the time
like there's there's different kinds of
energy that make
a person attractive
I pride myself on the fact that if you
come to one of my speeches you may just
laugh and cry in the same speech
that's that's what I call Unique pairing
in attraction a unique pairing is when
you find two different qualities that
are both attractive
but on their own can be a bit
two-dimensional
but when you find them in the same
person
that creates a 3d effect that is
mesmerizing
so if you find someone who's really sexy
but then they can be completely Goofy
and make you laugh
that's a unique pairing you're like whoa
that's normally someone's just sexy
normally someone's just funny and I want
to eat pizza with them but I don't want
to go home with them
now I find someone that is super sexy
and then after the fact I want to spend
all day with them laughing
well we might just have a relationship
you know that's a unique pairing and I
think that a lot of people have
forgotten that they've they've become
addicted
to a certain way of being that has
worked for them yeah if it's being like
hard-headed in business that's worked
for them but the problem is you're what
and usually it starts young right what
we get validated for we keep doing if
you're funny you keep being funny if
you're successful you keep acquiring
more success if you're
if people like you for your looks then
you double down on that we all have
those things that we got validated for
early on and our validations become our
mutations they become the things that we
go we we keep doubling down on and we
become less and less Diversified in our
energy our personality
you can't be you can't be one great song
you you have to be an album like every
everyone has to be an album some album
albums have sad songs they have happy
songs they have Up Tempo songs they have
slower songs you you gotta be able to be
all of those things and everyone should
ask themselves men and women alike
am I being an album
or am I being this this one great hit
and hoping that someone sticks around I
had a relationship with someone years
ago uh in my early 20s when I was just
as I was approaching my 20s and I
remember asking this person why it
months after the relationship ended I
was like why did you not want to be in
it anymore
and she said honestly I said
yes
I guess she said it got boring
she said you were so ambitious
and that was really really attractive at
first
but then it was all you were
it was like you it was all you could
talk about it was all we did was you
just talk about work and whatever it was
never anything else and it was a very
important lesson for me in my life
because I realized that one side of a
unique pairing
can actually Christopher Hitchens uh
once said that
the key in relationships is not allowing
your advantages to negate themselves oh
nice and the in his case what he was
talking about is he was obviously a
formidable debater on the stage
and he did it for a living but when he
was at home
he said when he was in an argument with
his wife
the guy on stage would come out
and really think about how to win this
argument and even after the fact he
would go away and like work on his case
and come back and be like all right I've
got the death blow to your argument
and he realized there was no points for
that in his relationship this was the
mother of his children
he was not trying to win a debate on a
stage
your advantages can negate themselves
it's worth everyone asking what are what
are the strengths I've been riding on
and where have they become my my
greatest weaknesses
what's the deal with uh masculine and
feminine energy and how does that relate
to kind of your coaching thesis and
anything like that do you know what's so
funny someone asked me this the other
day and I feel like I just had a
terrible answer
I don't
yeah
I feel like uh people have become very
caught up with the language of things
and
at the risk of reiterating the the point
I was just making I really do think that
well it's almost worth looking at what
would make me boring
if I was just masculine all the time
however you want to Define that if I was
just assertive and dominant and decisive
and ambitious and whatever if you want
to I I there were people I'm sure who uh
far more educated than me on what the
traditional masculine feminine actually
means but in terms of when I think of
what I associate it with if you were
just all those things all the time it
would be Terror I don't want to be
friends with a guy like that do you know
what I loved most about that trip to
Poland with Wim Hof was that we were a
group of guys that we were doing hard
things together like it was not easy we
were jumping off of cliffs into frozen
lakes and trekking up mountains in the
snow in our shorts but the that wasn't
even the part I enjoyed the most like
the part I enjoyed the most was when we
actually sat around and as a group of
guys everyone got vulnerable
and that we were doing the things that
wouldn't have been traditionally
associated with masculine energy
so
and even even win
who's this kind of like seems Invincible
said by the end of that trip he was like
this has really helped me because I feel
like I've been able to be vulnerable in
a way that I'm often not able to be and
that was that felt beautiful to me so
and because of that I felt so much more
connected
to that group of guys I felt like oh
I've I really feel like that I feel
bonded to you because I feel like I
understand you and I feel like oh all my
fears and the things I'm worried I'm not
good enough and they're being
articulated by you guys too and I feel
less alone as a result
um
so and it that in some ways it was like
doing all those hard things together
felt like it was almost a way of getting
to that yeah
if
I so I know all the men in my life
they are
they have the qualities that would be
traditionally I suppose associated with
like feminine energy
they have those things the best friends
I have have those things in spades
the
when I think about would I have ever
been attracted to someone who just had
feminine energy
I don't think that I would have been
I think that I always needed someone who
was able to be those things
but I also wanted someone who
could
be protective who could
step up and make tough decisions or show
up or be aggressive or be ambitious or
those things I wanted some in some sense
too like me and Audrey we this year did
um an event called hell on the hill
which is uh Jesse itzler
a friend of ours does an event every
year where you have to climb a hill a
hundred times is a brutal event it takes
four hours and it's very very hard to
complete you have to complete it within
four hours and and you have to go at
some Pace to complete this thing
and it brings down even some of the
toughest people that I've met
me and Audrey I did it last year and
then I dragged Audrey along to it this
year and
and it was so attractive it wouldn't
have mattered to me if she finished or
not but it was so attractive to me that
in the hardest moments of that
I saw a grit come out in her
that was I was like whoa hmm that's like
a there was a there was a gear in her
that even though there are times where
she's just very sweet and likes to for
me to protect her and take care of her
and
she's not she she in that moment was
like there was this grip
and I was like
this is inspiring to me because I'm
struggling right now
and she's like gritting this thing out
and she's not letting it beat her and I
saw this whole other side to her and
that for me was it was amazing it was
amazing to watch and it only made me
more attracted
so I when I say I think people get
caught up in language
I say that because
I think everyone should be looking for a
person who is able to
um
kind of hold that Duality inside of
themselves
instead of necessarily kind of being
attracted to something two-dimensional
because if you if you choose something
two-dimensional
your your kind of it's almost like
you're choosing to be happy half of the
time
because you're gonna okay you're gonna
date us hyper masculine guy and that's
gonna feel fun when you want him to be a
caveman
and it's really going to be depressing
and miserable when you need to
talk to someone who's able to be
vulnerable and relate and connect deeply
and be and reveal weakness it's going to
be utterly Miserable as a guy you can
date the person who's you know it's like
the ultimate feminine energy and then
find the oh my God I'm dating a princess
and I need right now this chapter of my
life calls for a teammate
not someone I just have to protect and
provide for I need it I need someone
who's climbing the hill with me right
now and instead they're asking me to
carry them yep
this is a problem so I I think whether
you call it masculine feminine or
whatever I honestly sometimes the
arguments the the way that they're
phrased it bores me because it's like we
spend all of our time
debating over theoretical nonsense
in the abstract like from a rational
perspective instead of just again coming
back to what's what's fun yeah fun is
dating someone who who has whatever you
want to call them both sides of the
spectrum
you may lean one way or the other in
terms of what you're looking for that's
fine but that's fun being attractive is
is being able to be different parts of
the spectrum at different times
and showing different sides of yourself
as is by the way being a to me being a
fully expressed
human being
is being able to you know there's this
part of me that doesn't normally come
out yeah and maybe that's not because it
doesn't exist maybe it's just because
it's never been entertained in you maybe
no one's ever encouraged it maybe people
told you you couldn't be that or you
weren't there
but all of a sudden you find oh there is
that part of me and you see that in all
walks of life you see women who have
always been told they can't and then all
of a sudden someone believes in them or
someone says what are you talking about
go try this and then they try and that
you know they're a beast and you go whoa
that's look that was always there
sometimes there's guys that are you know
you typically associate with a more
feminine energy and and that maybe they
have always done that too but then they
they go try something new they go take a
boxing class and they're like does this
brings out a side of me do I want to
live there all day no
but for that one hour a week this like
this brings out a side of me that I
don't normally get to entertain and it
feels good and it feels good not because
I'm sort of wearing a weird outfit that
I'm not supposed to be wearing and
that's fun no it feels good because I'm
I'm actually expressing a part of me
that I had convinced myself wasn't there
to be expressed in the first place
I hope that's not too uh
that makes perfect sense
um so
one thing I've often heard and I don't I
don't know to what extent this is just a
stereotype or if it's actually actually
a thing
um
the the Trope of women saying something
like you know I know I want to marry Mr
Wright but I find myself attracted to Mr
exciting and
I get I guess it's a situation that
you've dealt with I'm I'm kind of
guessing but and and I guess I wanted to
lead lead from that into the question of
to what extent is attraction a choice
and how much like if for example I find
myself attracted to the sort of person
who is not good for me and whatever
whatever that might look like can I
nudge my deep core into being attracted
to the nice guy or the whatever or is it
like uh like what's what what's going on
there what a fantastic question
um
I think that to an extent we Chase what
we know hmm
and sometimes being attracted to
something other than what we know or has
historically have been attracted to is
um a matter of curiosity
of actually opening ourselves up to a
different kind of person to a different
kind of situation and exploring it for
all it is we tend to be very we make up
our minds quite quickly about things
even labeling someone a nice person the
the you know Elaine the button would say
they're not that nice
do you know nice is a it's a kind of a
mask it could be as freaky as the
freakiest person you've ever met when it
comes down to it you know this this idea
of labeling someone a nice person is um
or labeling someone the bad boy why what
because they didn't call you for three
days that makes them a bad boy
you know but because they were a bit of
a jerk to the to someone like they're
the bad boy like what are you
what is that what is that label
do you think that the bad boy all of the
time
like you think they're that person 24
hours a day of course they're not but
based on this label you've given them
they're exciting based on this label
you've given this person they're boring
so I think that yes of course there is a
sense of there's a kind of reflexive
attraction that we can have for people
but I think that's a sometimes a lack of
imagination and a lack of curiosity if
you took time to actually get to know
somebody I'm not saying you go on a date
with someone where there's absolutely
zero chemistry and you just keep hitting
and hoping yeah and going oh I'll see
them again because maybe one day
chemistry could come about no I I don't
believe that
but
I always think if if you feel like some
some kind of interesting tickle in a
direction that you haven't felt it
before and you go well this isn't
normally my type or this isn't normally
my personal this isn't I feel something
follow that
give that chance because that might
actually lead you somewhere you've never
been before and where you've never been
before might be
the answer
I think that we we prejudge a lot we
judge what we're supposed to have what
we think our friends and family would
would validate yeah you know oh he's
really good looking well done yeah you
know and you so you kind of start
looking for that even though you might
find that an attraction with this person
that doesn't look like that
you feel validated by the fact that
other people are
are giving you the the social proof
around that person so you feel like you
keep and that's by the way it's how
people get themselves in so much trouble
they show off their their partner and
their oh my God he's so tall handsome
and successful look at you good job
and they're miserable at home with this
person but every time they go out and
hear
well he's he's very impressive and they
go oh I should like oh yeah I should I
should I should be grateful this
person's amazing I should continue to be
grateful you know
so we have to be careful of the outside
conditioning
and we also have to be careful Dr Romani
would and people in her profession uh
psychologists would talk about the kind
of the trauma Bond
that exists when we've been used to you
know a parent that neglected us or that
that was very hot and cold in our lives
and that becomes kind of what we know
and so we get attracted to to that
behavior in others
um and we try and complete a journey
that never felt finished When We Were
Young And it so we also have to be very
careful of what we're labeling
attraction am I labeling this trauma and
this heightened sense of anxiety that I
have around you because you're fickle
and you never make me feel secure am I
labeling that excitement oh I I just
what is it I've got with this person I
and the more they they don't call me the
more I'm like oh they there's something
special about this one why is it why why
are they getting more attractive the
less they try yeah what's going on here
you know we have to really suspect those
things in ourselves
and I think that an another way of
looking at attraction and again I'm not
this I'm not an advocate for don't care
about chemistry care about chemistry but
if you start to lay look at all the
things that would make an incredible
partner
and
and would make you feel secure and at
peace
and if you start valuing kind of an a
real sense of deep peace
over
the kind of drug-fueled high
then you are going to start looking at
people a little differently because
you're not going to over index for
chemistry you may still see it as
necessary it's a necessary ingredient
but I don't have to live my life trying
to find the greatest chemistry of my
life
it's the same way
you know when it comes to food or drugs
there's a feeling of I'm looking for the
greatest High
but the greatest High isn't the thing
that will make you the happiest
sustainably
so
at a certain point in life I think we we
can we sometimes come to terms with what
feels like a boring conclusion yep that
that feeling better and I'm still
learning this with food so I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna talk like I've got all
this figured out but
feeling better consistently is
just even though it means sometimes not
eating that thing or not doing that
thing and that feels frustrating or
boring whatever it's
it's I just value it more
a value being uh feeling peace in my
life and feeling a sense of of
kind of a going into my day with a sense
of Happiness over feeling at
an astronomical High because of a drug I
just took
that I get for three hours
and then it gets bad
you know like it's
a certain point
I I almost feel like you have to say
having a nutritional
lasting sense of happiness
uh starts to win over looking for the
high that cannot be sustained
um and I I don't think we we look enough
for people who
where we've where we truly as my fiance
would put it chase the right things you
always reliably pay the price for
chasing the wrong things it may be it
may be uh it may be fun it often is
and it may work for a minute hmm
but you always end up having to come you
always have to turn back at some point
you always end up having to come back to
chasing the right things at some point
if you want to be happy and I think that
a lot of us
the different stages of our life go on
those detours of chasing the wrong
things I certainly have my time kind of
and I'm I'm sure I'll fall into the Trap
again at different points in my life but
you you know a lot of people in their
20s you have to chase the wrong things
and you go on those detours and
um what did I see recently and Lord the
new Lord of the Rings I haven't seen it
yet okay I won't ruin anything but
there's just a there's a line in it
where someone says sometimes you have to
um I think he says you sometimes you
have to touch the darkness in order to
know which way the light is hmm and
you know you kind of don't I don't know
if anyone gets to just
know and appreciate the right things
unless they have come face to face and
have some brush-ins with the wrong
things whether it's in the form of a
tremendous heartbreak from someone who
was very charismatic and exciting
um or whether it really is with alcohol
or whatever other highs life offers and
it there's always there's always going
to be something that
you kind of feel like you've cracked it
like no no I can make this work for me
and then you realize you can't so that's
that's my I try to answer to the
attraction question be willing to be
attracted to things and follow feelings
that are unusual to you and maybe a
little
scary not because there's there's red
flags but because it's a represents
something new and different and a
different type be prepared to uh make
your own mind up on how wonderful
someone is even if your friends don't
applaud how tall dark and handsome that
person is or how gorgeous that person is
um yeah have a real sense of what they
offer and and what does that look like
over a long timeline
um a couple questions about long-term
relationships so uh
honeymoon phase what's what's the deal
with that yeah I you know I'm I'm I
don't want to be really careful on this
because
talking uh from a place of humility I
I've not been in the kinds of long-term
relationships that other people have I'm
now engaged
um incredibly uh Happy
and excited about the future
um but there will be people who
you know have like Esther perel's work
is a really big influence for me because
this is someone who not only has had a
long-term marriage but has written
extensively on the subject of Love and
Desire yeah in relationships and I would
absolutely Point people to her book
mating in captivity which I think is an
extraordinary read and something that so
many people can learn from to paraphrase
Esther's work which is no doubt much
more eloquently put in her book she says
that there's love and there's desire and
that love
um
well let's start with desire desire is
what exists first we see someone we
become attracted to them and we desire
them and we want to close down the space
between us and Them desire exists in the
space right the mystery who are you what
are you all about could you like me
could I win you over could you know I
want to know you and then as someone
says yes
you have the building of love
so we start to know each other we start
to get closer and closer and closer and
closer and closer and we have this
feeling of kind of Oneness between us
and and all of that Fosters feelings of
love
uh as Esther would put it the Paradox
becomes how do you continue to desire
that which you already have
and so now as you kind of become that
unit
there's less space between you they may
feel like there's no space between you
and so desire becomes suffocated because
desire exists in that space
and then you so then you enter that
world of well what does
what does desire look like in a long
term
context we don't want to play a game in
a long-term relationship where we kind
of are constantly making our partner
feel on edge yeah so that there's a
sense of danger and and yet
desire sometimes wants a sense of danger
desire sometimes wants a sense of
mystery desire wants a sense of
spontaneity of the new of the
unrecognizable now people want it to
differing extents right the honeymoon
period is going to be much more
important to some people than others
because some people are are wired and
engineered to want security
so for them love is going to be much
more important for them to achieve than
to maintain feelings of desire for other
people they're engineered in the
opposite way it's much more important
for them to constantly feel like that
excitement than it is for them to feel
safety not that they don't want to feel
safe at all but it's just the balance is
different
and so I think what's kind of
interesting is
firstly to to to try to
find somebody who's not engineered
completely differently than you
where they you know it's all love and no
desire or it's all desire and no love
because that's going to be miserable
but you may find that you're not
calibrated exactly the same in those two
things and that's okay
but
that to me is where it's really
important to listen
to your partner's needs we we get so
caught up in a relationship in figuring
out what we need what's my love language
what what makes me feel loved and the
and the dangerous thing is that
we start giving to somebody else what we
would wish they would give to us so if
we like security then and we think
that's the highest thing you can give
someone then we start going out of our
way to give them as much security as
possible I love you I love you I love
you I love you I'll never leave you I
think you're the most amazing person on
Earth and so on we give them lots and
lots of security right and we end up
giving them that thing that We crave but
it doesn't mean you're wrong for craving
it just means that you're you're not
necessarily listening
to what that person requires because
they may just be engineered a little
different so I think it's really
valuable to just think about what
what are the things
that make my partner that Stoke desire
in my partner because in a way that to
me is what the honeymoon the honeymoon
period is a couple of things firstly
it's thinking we're perfect I think
you're perfect you think I'm perfect and
that just feels unbelievable and idyllic
and then we realize we're not perfect
and they go you go through a storming
period and the dust settles and now you
have a real relationship where we
actually see each other and say I'm
still here even though I really see you
now that's the to me that's the
transition into a real relationship
um but but beyond that it's also I think
the the honeymoon period is that period
of intense desire yeah
I think it's worth paying attention
as you transition in your relationship
to whatever the next phase is really pay
attention to what are the moments where
my partner
feels desire
and this can be a kind of exercise in
really paying attention like right write
them down it may sound weird to people
but like right because you will forget
write down I just did this thing tonight
I just wore a completely different kind
of outfit and something about that
outfit really got them going yeah I'm
not even saying it was a really sexy
outfit it might be a an outfit you
wouldn't even even imagined was sexy to
them yeah but something about that
outfit did it for them yeah you're like
okay noted yeah
oh I just went away with my friends for
a weekend
and when I came back there was this
intensity okay that's interesting
um
all of those little moments are they're
like a formula
that can help you sustain that desire
within a relationship and I think when
you stop paying attention to those
things it's another way of not paying
attention to the health of your
relationship the health of your
relationship isn't two-dimensional it's
not just
how many things have I done for my
partner today
but I don't understand why they're so
ungrateful I I made them this I did this
I called them at the end of that and
asked them how it went I did that I did
it okay that's all of that is beautiful
but
but value in a relationship isn't too
dimensional
sometimes value to someone is hey you
haven't seen your friends in a minute
you should go see your friends
like go hang out with that you haven't
seen those two friends in a while you
should go hang out with them are you
sure what really I feel like you'd be a
oh I'll be good I'll chill I'm gonna do
some stuff I really wanna do but you
should go do that that's another form of
value if if you crave security that
might be unnatural to you because you
might be like I don't want them to go
out with their friends and leave me for
a night yeah but that might be the very
thing that makes them go whoa yeah I've
never had anyone do that before I've
never had anyone encourage me to go and
have time with people I care about
they're always sort of jealously
guarding my presence and my time so
there's another form of value it
that to me is like real Mastery in in
relationships is going beyond what is
comfortable to give beyond what is feels
normal for you to give and really
listening to
what what makes them feel a certain way
whether it's love or desire what Stokes
that in that person I mean pay attention
so that I can replicate that in the
future
amazing Matthew thank you so much it's
been wonderful uh we still have 13 years
of your backstory to dive into and the
business model around it and all that
kind of stuff so we're going to do a
part two sometime either when you're
back in London or potentially when I get
a visa to come visit La
um thank you so much this has been
absolutely wonderful conversation uh
where can people find out more about you
uh well Thursday thank you for having me
because that was an amazing amazing
questions I I would say to anyone who is
going through challenges in their love
life
um if you go to
yourdatingsolution.com uh and
specifically if you're a woman you will
find a a quiz there that you can take
and it will suggest to you my best
solution to what you're going through so
that's pretty cool
um if you want a really fun freebie and
you're trying to get over someone uh go
to moveonstrong.com which is going to
help anyone who's going through tough
times right now with someone in their
life or someone they're trying to move
on from and I'm also Instagram at the
Matthew Hussey for anyone who just wants
to follow me casually there nice and
I'll put links to all these things in
the show notes and the video description
so thank you so much for coming on
thanks man appreciate you all right so
that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye